this question comes from matt
in wisconsin says my fiance and i both
have full-time jobs and have worked hard
to get where we are
i'm an accountant heading towards my cpa
i have one and a half semesters left
before i plan to sit for the exam
she's a doctor pretty solid in her
profession at this time no debt
perfect credit score i'm going to school
as a result of built up some debt she
wants me to sign a prenup
she's a doctor and has worked hard for
where she is
so i do sort of get it i'm living
paycheck to paycheck
i need help or at least some advice i'm
not sure how i feel
about the prenup uh
matt i don't know how much debt you have
uh but she ain't that special
she's not as special she thinks she is
so
uh the only time i recommend a prenup is
in
extreme number situations and these are
not extreme she simply makes more new
and she's responsible and she doesn't
like your responsibility
i think she doesn't want to marry you
sir
and uh and and she wants to marry you
but oh well not if there's any possible
pain involved
well let me help you with this there's
going to be pain involved in being
married
period so uh you know if i if i run into
somebody where one
person has you know 5 or 10 million
dollars and one person has zero
yeah i'll probably put a prenup on that
one it's really not for the two
individuals
that are getting married but more for
the weirdness that is around them in
their life
because their stupid mother-in-law
always got some idea she's entitled to
the new son-in-law's money or some weird
crap
and that's the stuff i run into but just
i'm a doctor
and i make money i'll kiss my butt
i mean give me a break the arrogance of
that's unbelievable
so no no no i think you could need some
pre-marriage counseling
maybe you can work through this issue
but she needs to love you more than she
loves money
and she hasn't got that much money
there's not that much involved here
there's not an extreme thing going on
here at all
um so there you go
now i had one guy uh caught one lady
called and said her fiance
had a classic car and he wanted a prenup
and i'm like uh he loves the car more
than you
okay if this is my daughter we're not
getting married
not have i got any say-so in the
situation so
no the thing is this
um when someone works really really hard
like you guys have worked in your fields
cpa docs
whatever lawyers spend a lot of money a
lot of time becoming a professional
that is a wonderful thing and is an
indicator that you're bright people
but it is also an indicator that you've
had such a singular focus
that you're willing to put the career
issues and the income associated with a
career ahead of relationships
and that means i'm not going to go
forward with that one
not until we can get that solved because
we don't want um
we don't want this career to be um
the thing because it's all about her
being a doc more than it is her being
your wife
and so i don't just old man talking so
you do whatever you want to do
but the problem is you ask my opinion
around here i'll give it to you
because i am an expert on my opinion
and um so far it's worked out pretty
good for me
most the time sometimes i step in it up
to my knees but
most the time pretty much the deal
here's the good news is matt you get to
do whatever you want to do
but you ask me and that's what i would
do pre-marriage counseling until there's
no prenup needed
or until the engagement is broken off